so your project's coming out top of your
hopefully yeah man this car is stolen is
wifey gonna be on the project she's not
on the project you know what she's done
with music she's just done
done with features done with it all
i i can't speak for right now i'm saying
i'm hoping that the energy
is stays positive and she continues
because i don't want her to stop you
know what i'm saying but i'm awesome i
feel like she's so talented and like
somehow still hasn't even met her peak
yet but that's the issue that's why she
wanted to stop because it's like um
whatever that wall is she doesn't
understand the wall and it's like now
if it's going to like
hurt her mentally
it's not worth dealing with i'm saying
she's like i've been doing that for so
long and it hasn't brought me to
happiness i need and before it becomes a
point where
she doesn't love music
or the effect like you said if it
affects your happiness in the name
that's what i'm saying though but it's
like peace some of that is like
i want to continue to love music and it
becomes now i think of music as a game
maybe and it's yeah it's like it becomes
work or like i got to figure out
how to do this or how to she wants it to
be like she goes to the studio and it
just be carefree again yeah and just
making music and singing with a heart
and it ain't all this thought like you
don't want to come out in the label
already like yeah well could you think
you could say this it's like
yeah all that after a while it's like i
can't imagine 15 years of somebody
keeping me in a box and trying to oh
this is hot right now you should follow
behind this girl and it's like dog like
i just want to do my thing and turn my
album in y'all put the money behind it
go out to them let me shoot my videos
let me go do my show that's how it and
it's like once you're done with it yeah
once it's not that harmony like i can
understand that for her doing it for so
long it's like it got to be a headache
so i get it but i just hope that and so
before she comes back because she's
incredible you know what i'm saying like
i i spend that album before i go to
sleep i'm saying i'm still a fan even
though i'm a husband you know what i'm
saying so it's like
i still want her to come back so i don't
you know what i'm saying put too much
pressure on anything we just sort of let
it happen let the energy happen hope she
come back